I make this statement on behalf of my
brother
Olivia's loving father John Francis
Pratt he wasn't completely heartbroken
his oldest her older sisters Casey and
Kelsey and the rest of the Pratt Family
following the conviction of Cashman and
his sentence today we'd like to say we
are happy with the outcome but we will
not be celebrating as nothing will fill
the Gap left in our lives following the
loss of Olivia
we would like to thank the jury for the
correct visit and the witness who showed
courage and stood up for Olivia goodbye
giving evidence we listen to you
you would also like to thank mate's side
police and the officers from across the
country who assisted in the
investigation the legal team especially
Mr McLachlan it's the hard way in
getting Justice for art Olivia
we would like to thank our flows Jamie
Justin and Nikki the support they have
given my brother and family over the
hardest seven months of our lives our
thoughts are also with the families of
Sam Rich rimmer Ashley Dale
Jacqueline Russa
[Applause]
and Ellie Edwards
we hope you get the Justice your loved
ones they deserve our greatest hope is
for this conviction to lead to more guns
and especially those used in the Mesa of
Olivia to be handed in to the police so
though no other families must go through
this tragedy lastly I would like to say
Olivia Pratt Corbell died a scared
nine-year-old and we hope Cashman is
haunted by this knowledge for the rest
of his life
thank you